now on your new radio show one of your
co-hosts daily Cannon baby we blasted
daily Cannon your co-host is one of the
women you had a baby with now that's got
to set up that's true right I got that
absolutely true DJ Abby De la Rosa to
the other ladies get jealous or upset
with you they're like Nick for crisis
I see all right well it could I mean you
know what I think I think everybody has
their own thing I mean the beautiful
thing about Abby is I met her in a radio
space she was she was working at uh I
heart out out here in LA in in L.A and
uh she was just I had never seen a radio
personality and an actual DJ uh and and
she had her own show and I was like whoa
she's so dope and that's kind of you
know I fell in love with her energy then
so I was like when I started my new show
I was like the only DJ I want is you
know you're in love with my children so
you're in love with Abby De la Rosa of
course I always say I'm in love I'm in
love with energy that's what I'm you
love her anyway I love her energy the
daily Canon radio show premieres April
24th on amp
foreign